what's up everyone
so Avengers for reshoots have been well
underway for a couple of weeks now and
there have even been some rumors that
they're not only just reshooting some
scenes but they're actually changing the
story and changing the ending a little
bit this could be due to the Disney Fox
acquisition and the possibility of new
characters being able to be introduced
into the MCU but since it's not 100%
completely finalized and Disney doesn't
officially own all of the characters yet
I don't think this is the case we know
that they shot infinity war and Avengers
for back-to-back one right after the
other so it's most likely that the Russo
brothers or the writers just had some
more ideas regardless it's been pretty
cool to see some of these leaks set
photos come out and try to guess what's
going on and today I'm going to be
talking about Captain America quick
reminder about the giveaway I'm doing
I'm giving away a copy of Avengers
infinity war on blu-ray some special
edition posters and some special
memorabilia from our partners over at
silk and cotton all you have to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts
and your favorite superhero you can also
check out silk and cotton in the link
below so we've gotten a few looks at
Steve Rogers / Captain America since
infinity Wars come out the first one was
this official promo poster and a lot of
people were wondering if this was real
or fake it's real they used it at Cinna
Europe so it's a hundred percent real
and there's recently been some high-res
animated versions going around as well
and the biggest thing that we saw from
this poster of Captain America is that
he is no longer The Secret Avengers
Captain America he wasn't really Captain
America in Avengers infinity war he
hasn't actually really been Captain
America since the events of civil war
baloney
you don't deserve it my father made that
you
[Music]
all throughout infinity war Steve Rogers
was rocking the beard the long hair and
no star on his uniform since the events
of Civil War he's been an outlaw and
he's been wanted and this is true
throughout all the events of infinity
war and we know that when he returns to
the Avengers headquarters and sees Ross
and Ross tells Rhodey to arrest him
so it's widely believed that after Civil
War Steve gave up the mantle of Captain
America him Natasha and Sam went about
their own business doing their own
missions which was a tribute to the
secret of interest comic line but then
of course they came back fought daños in
Wakanda and lost so this promo art comes
out and everybody says captain's back no
more beard he's clean-cut
he's got the star back on his chest he's
back but of course it's promo art so who
really knows but with the Avengers for
reshoots happening and leaked photos
coming out we know now and all the
photos that we've seen he's clean cut
his hair shorter we haven't seen him in
uniform yet but it does seem like the
old Captain America is back and it makes
a lot of sense seeing as how half of the
universe just got wiped away from
existence right now the world needs
Captain America and not just Captain
America Iron Man as well the world needs
the two of them to reconnect they need
the Avengers and Steve Rogers and Tony
Stark both know this so at some point
during Avengers 4 the Avengers will
regroup and regather they'll put all
their differences aside and once more
become the Avengers at which case Steve
Rogers will once again take on the
mantle of Captain America this is
probably especially true since it's the
last movie for Chris Evans as Captain
America it's been very speculated for a
long time since he hasn't renewed his
contract but he himself has come out and
said that this will indeed be his last
movie and about a week ago he posted on
Twitter this photo with the caption
senior year hashtag a for senior year
obviously implying that it's his last
year last movie and he is clean-cut and
his hair is shorter in this picture as
well so it does seem that in a vendor's
war we're going to see Steve Rogers take
on the mantle of Captain America
again I'm sure you're all just as
excited as I am to see this happen to
see The Avengers get back together and
try to take on Thanos let me know how
you all feel and let me know what you
think about this being the last movie
that Chris Evans will be playing Captain
America let me know what you think in
the comments below
and again another reminder about the
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero thank you so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]